This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave, Netflix, and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。获取Bell纯光纤互联网，包含Crave、Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94加元起。互联网价格保证两年，需签订两年合约并使用自动付款优惠。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接即一切。在新的播客节目《Solita》中，我们分享女性独自旅行的真实混乱经历。我可以等四个小时坐下一班巴士，或者这个陌生男人
is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, black literature. I'm Jack Quist-Peace Thomas, and on this season of the Black Lits podcast, we're outside asking why. They don't want a whole bunch of little Ella bakers,
提议让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是Julie Pinero，我独自旅行，因为这是一个难得的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代怜悯。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Solita》。是否存在一种针对文学的流行病？更具体地说，是针对黑人文学。我是Jack Quist-Peace Thomas，在这一季的《Black Lits》播客中，我们走出来询问原因。他们不想要一大堆像Ella Baker、
Michael Waxes and Martin Luther King running around. And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black Reading Month, the only real question is, what are you reading next? Listen to BlackLit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast,
Michael Waxes和Martin Luther King那样的人到处跑。当你审视许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，唯一真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《BlackLit》，请在我们的IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcast、
or wherever you get your podcast. What up, y'all? This your main man, Memphis Bleak right here. host of that Rock Solid podcast and each week we bring in you exclusive looks inside music everything happening inside the culture some of the best conversations
或任何你获取播客的地方收听。大家好，我是你们的主力，Memphis Bleak，是《Rock Solid》播客的主持人。每周我们都会带给你们关于音乐的独家视角，以及文化内部发生的一切，还有一些最好的对话，
were the biggest names in the game you had a little bit more pressure to be good and they didn't care if you was a girl like you wasn't getting no points if you're not trashed you better be not just good you better be great listen to Rock Solid on Black Effect Podcast Network
都是业内最大牌的人物。你会有更大的压力去表现出色，他们不在乎你是不是女孩，如果你表现得不好，你就得不到任何认可。你最好不仅是好，你得是伟大。在Black Effect播客网络上收听《Rock Solid》，
iHeartRadio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you streamed podcast. Hey there everybody, Amy Robock and TJ Holmes here from the Amy and TJ podcast. A lot of times the story of the day is what we're all talking about and buzzing about. And yes, sometimes it's Love Island and sometimes it's Serena, Robes. Coming back to the U.S. Open, sometimes it's obsession and Spider-Man making box office history. Hopefully, Rose, people get our point. Listen to Amy and TJ on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you live. listen to podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s,
IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方。大家好，我是Amy Robock和TJ Holmes，来自《Amy and TJ》播客。很多时候，当天的故事就是我们大家都在谈论和热议的话题。是的，有时是《Love Island》，有时是Serena Williams重返美国网球公开赛，有时是《Obsession》和《蜘蛛侠》创造票房历史。希望Rose，大家能明白我们的意思。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Amy and TJ》。大家好。我是Jemma Spike，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，
the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. We talk a lot about emotion and we talk a lot about mental well-being very broadly on this podcast. But today I wanted to literally devote our full 30-minute episode to one emotion and one emotion only, sadness. Being sad in all of its forms, whether it's heartbreak, whether it's grief, whether it's yearning or loss, is something we naturally want to avoid. right? You know, there is this core idea that humans run from pain and run towards pleasure. And
这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要剖析你二十多岁的心理。在这个播客中，我们谈论了很多关于情绪和心理健康的话题。但今天，我想把我们完整的30分钟节目专门献给一种情绪，而且只有一种情绪：悲伤。以各种形式感到悲伤，无论是心碎、悲痛、渴望还是失落，都是我们天生想要避免的事情，对吧？你知道，人类逃避痛苦、追求快乐这一核心理念是存在的，而
sadness is the opposite of pleasure. It's the opposite of all things nice. But we also can't deny that there is something about sadness that deep down just feels a little bit good sometimes. Listening to sad songs, for example, scratches and itch, watching sad movies can leave us with this really intense form of clarity, just letting yourself cry, you know, or feel self-pity, that feels good. It kind of clears the air sometimes. The reason sadness feels so nice and kind of like a guilty pleasure is deeply psychological and it comes down to something known as the tragedy paradox. Basically, what we think hurts us most also seems to give us a lot of pleasure, but also a deeper connection to our humanness. Even the ancient Greeks, even the
悲伤是快乐的对立面。它是所有美好事物的对立面。但我们也无法否认，悲伤中确实有一些东西，在内心深处有时感觉还不错。例如，听悲伤的歌能满足某种需求，看悲伤的电影能给我们带来一种非常强烈的清晰感，让自己哭出来，或者感受自怜，这感觉很好。它有时能净化空气。悲伤之所以感觉如此美好，甚至像是一种“罪恶的快感”，是深层的心理原因，这归结为一种被称为“悲剧悖论”的现象。基本上，我们认为最伤害我们的东西，似乎也给了我们很多快乐，同时也让我们与人性有了更深层的联系。即使是古希腊人，即使是
ancient Romans, they spoke about this, they spoke about specifically this human urge to dangle near the cliff of despair, as they very much, as they put it in a very dramatic sense. And it is a feeling that we still have today, albeit a little bit less dramatic. Another important factor at play is something called emo diversity. Truly enjoying your life and of course your 20s, you know, it doesn't just come from being happy all the time. It comes from emotional variety and it comes from experiencing the shift. between different emotional states that puts the different ends of the emotional spectrum into perspective.
古罗马人，他们也谈论过这一点，他们特别谈论了这种人类徘徊在绝望悬崖边缘的冲动，正如他们以非常戏剧性的方式所表达的那样。这是一种我们今天仍然拥有的感觉，尽管没那么戏剧化。另一个重要的因素是所谓的“情绪多样性”。真正享受你的生活，当然还有你的二十多岁，不仅仅来自于一直快乐。它来自于情绪的多样性，来自于体验不同情绪状态之间的转换，这使得情绪光谱的两端有了视角。
The deep joy of having a truly amazing great day, it just wouldn't be as special if you didn't, kind of at the back of your mind, remember what it felt like to have a really awful day. Some research even suggests that people who don't allow themselves to truly feel the full spectrum of emotions, don't allow themselves to feel sad, actually may be worse off, psychologically, emotionally, socially, even if they seemingly look happier from the outside. So today, I want to just explore why being sad sometimes feels so good, but also that deep psychological, dare I say, benefit that we come across when we embrace sadness. If that sounds counterintuitive, if that sounds strange, if that sounds opposite to your experience,
拥有真正美好的一天所带来的深层快乐，如果你在潜意识里不记得度过糟糕的一天是什么感觉，那它就不会那么特别。一些研究甚至表明，那些不允许自己真正感受完整情绪光谱、不允许自己感到悲伤的人，在心理、情感和社会层面上可能反而更糟糕，即使他们从外表上看似乎更快乐。所以今天，我想探讨一下为什么有时感到悲伤感觉这么好，以及当我们拥抱悲伤时，我们所获得的深层心理（我敢说是）益处。如果这听起来违反直觉，如果这听起来很奇怪，如果这听起来与你的经历相反，
I promise the science and the research will make a lot more sense once we get into it. So without further ado, let's talk about sadness. Let's talk about why it feels so weirdly enjoyable. As a species and as a culture, I think it's safe to say we are incredibly wary of sadness. And we are very, very quick to do anything in our power to just get rid of it. Get rid of the feeling when it pops up, especially when it pops up on invited. We quash it with all sorts of things. We quash it with layers and layers of distraction and with our phones,
我保证，一旦我们深入了解，科学和研究就会更有意义。所以事不宜迟，让我们谈谈悲伤。让我们谈谈为什么它感觉如此奇怪地令人愉悦。作为一个物种和一个文化，我认为可以肯定地说，我们对悲伤非常警惕。我们非常、非常迅速地尽一切努力去摆脱它。当这种感觉出现时，尤其是当它不请自来时，我们要摆脱它。我们用各种各样的方式压制它。我们用一层又一层的分心和我们的手机来压制它，
with elaborate wellness routines, with plans, with busyness, whatever you can, whatever you can think of. We will throw all of our available resources at this dark emotion until it kind of leaves us alone. I think the reason we do this is twofold. A, we have a lot of stigma towards these feelings, towards feelings of sadness, anger, madness and that's wrapped up in our stigma towards poor mental health. And B, it's because we often confuse sadness with suffering or with sorrow. And we are really fearful that if we were to let
用精心设计的健康常规、计划、忙碌，无论你能想到什么。我们会把所有可用的资源都投入到这种黑暗的情绪中，直到它离开我们。我认为我们这样做的原因有两个。A，我们对这些感觉，对悲伤、愤怒、疯狂的感觉有很多污名化，这与我们对心理健康状况不佳的污名化有关。B，是因为我们经常把悲伤与受苦或哀伤混为一谈。我们非常害怕，如果我们让
our sadness get too big, it would transform into this big monster of an emotion that is just so much harder to deal with. The thing is, they're very different. And this is why it's so important to distinguish between being sad, the feeling, and a state of true pain and suffering. If we want to access the benefits of being sad. You have to know the difference. And this is how I would distinguish them. Sadness is a temporary emotional state. It is usually tied to something specific that has happened, that has changed, that has been lost. And that might be a rejection. It might be disappointment that you didn't get a job or that you've missed out on something. It might be loneliness, homesickness, grief, maybe just the awareness that your life isn't the same as it
我们的悲伤变得太大，它会变成一个巨大的情绪怪物，让人更难处理。问题是，它们非常不同。这就是为什么区分“悲伤”（这种感觉）和“真正的痛苦与受苦状态”如此重要。如果你想获得悲伤的好处，你必须知道区别。这就是我区分它们的方式。悲伤是一种暂时性的情绪状态。它通常与发生、改变或失去的特定事物有关。那可能是一次拒绝。可能是因为没得到工作或错过了某事而感到的失望。可能是孤独、思乡、悲痛，也许只是意识到你的生活不再像
once was, it's a very heavy emotion, but it kind of will pass. It softens after a while. Sorrow and suffering, on the other hand, are what we would call prolonged mental states. It's just more consuming. It lasts longer. It's a combination of a lot of things, and it tends to bleed into all other states of being. So what I mean by that is you can be sad, but then you can go to the movies or go for a walk with your friends and be distracted from that feeling. And pretty soon you cannot notice that you can shift to a different feeling. The same just can't be said for suffering or sorrow. They are always there.
过去那样了，这是一种非常沉重的情绪，但它会过去。过了一会儿它会变软。另一方面，哀伤和受苦是我们所说的长期心理状态。它更具消耗性。它持续时间更长。它是许多事物的组合，并且往往会渗透到所有其他存在状态中。我的意思是，你可以感到悲伤，但随后你可以去看电影或和朋友散步，从而从那种感觉中分心。很快你就会发现你可以转换到另一种感觉。但对于受苦或哀伤，情况就不同了。它们总是存在。
Same with depression, for that matter. They're just, they're constants for the time being. The best way I've seen it described is that sadness is like the rain. Depression is the season of winter. So on face value, you know, the big reason I think we villainize sadness or any kind of so-called negative emotion is because we associate it with these biggest states of being that feel. or much more difficult to handle. But deep down, we know they're not the same. We know that sadness and sorrow are different. And that is revealed to us through our enjoyment of sadness. Our enjoyment of sadness through art, through self-pity, and through catharsis, it kind of like
抑郁症也是如此。它们只是暂时的常态。我见过最好的描述是：悲伤就像雨，抑郁症就像冬天。所以从表面上看，我认为我们妖魔化悲伤或任何所谓的负面情绪的很大原因，是因为我们将它与这些感觉更难处理的巨大存在状态联系在一起。但内心深处，我们知道它们并不相同。我们知道悲伤和哀伤是不同的。这一点通过我们对悲伤的享受表现出来。我们通过艺术、自怜和宣泄来享受悲伤，它有点像
sneaks into our psyche, right? There is this desire to be closer to this feeling that we are told to avoid. One explanation is that there is a fundamental difference between experiencing sadness and experiencing actual threat. When something genuinely sad happens to you, the emotion usually arrives alongside a whole collection of other unpleasant experiences. If somebody breaks up with you, for example, you're not just sad. You are also anxious. You're anxious about what's on the other side of this experience. You are probably worried that you're never going to meet somebody else. You're embarrassed about being rejected about maybe not seeing it coming. One of my closest friends is going through this right now and it's not sadness that is the problem. Sadness is definitely
潜入我们的心灵，对吧？有一种渴望去接近这种被告知要避免的感觉。一种解释是，体验悲伤和体验真正的威胁之间存在根本区别。当真正悲伤的事情发生在你身上时，这种情绪通常伴随着一系列其他不愉快的经历。例如，如果有人和你分手，你不仅仅是悲伤。你还感到焦虑。你对这段经历之后会发生什么感到焦虑。你可能担心你永远不会再遇到别人。你对被拒绝感到尴尬，对可能没预料到这一点感到尴尬。我最亲密的朋友之一现在正在经历这个，问题不在于悲伤。悲伤绝对
there. It's just all the other stuff that you don't expect when a relationship ends. Just being sad is the least of her worries. It's wrapped up in so much other stuff. So sad art, sad music, sad movies remove a lot of that threat whilst preserving the emotion. If I watch a movie where somebody, you know, loses the love of their life, I can I can empathize with that character and I can experience something that maybe resembles grief, some part of me also understands that I'm still safe. So nobody I know has died. It's a movie. My relationship hasn't ended. I haven't lost anything. I am detached. Research is looking at pleasurable sadness, as we call it. Talk about this in terms of psychological distance. And it's one of the reasons that allows sadness to become enjoyable.
在那里。只是关系结束时你没预料到的所有其他事情。仅仅感到悲伤是她最不用担心的事情。它被包裹在太多其他事情中了。所以悲伤的艺术、悲伤的音乐、悲伤的电影消除了很多那种威胁，同时保留了情绪。如果我看一部电影，有人失去了他们一生的挚爱，我可以与那个角色产生共鸣，我可以体验到某种类似于悲痛的东西，但我内心的一部分也明白我仍然是安全的。所以没有我认识的人死去。这只是一部电影。我的关系没有结束。我没有失去任何东西。我是超然的。研究正在关注所谓的“愉悦的悲伤”。谈论这个时会提到“心理距离”。这是允许悲伤变得令人愉悦的原因之一。
We get access to the emotional intensity without necessarily having to pay the real world price that normally produces it. It's why we all enjoy dramatic entertainment. I would say most of us do actually, because we enjoy it because it's not happening to us. There's a lot of research to back this up, which basically suggests when we're listening to sad music in particular, what we're experiencing isn't actually pure sadness. It's something a little bit more nuanced. So there was one study published in 2014 and looked at 772 participants from around the world. And it found that it wasn't just sadness people were experiencing when they listened to sad music. It was nostalgia. It was what they called the reward of imagination. It was emotional regulation. It was empathy. And most importantly,
我们获得了情绪强度，而不必支付通常产生这种强度的现实世界代价。这就是为什么我们都喜欢戏剧性的娱乐。我想我们大多数人确实喜欢，因为我们喜欢它，因为它没有发生在我们身上。有很多研究支持这一点，基本上表明当我们听悲伤的音乐时，我们体验到的实际上并不是纯粹的悲伤。它更微妙一些。2014年发表的一项研究调查了来自世界各地的772名参与者。研究发现，人们在听悲伤音乐时体验到的不仅仅是悲伤。那是怀旧。那是所谓的“想象力的奖励”。那是情绪调节。那是同理心。最重要的是，
it was all of that without real life implications. And if the songs did match a situation that somebody was going through, it actually provided a bit of a container for that. feeling. You know, I listen to the sad song. I feel sad for the length of the song. The song ends. The sadness may also end. This actually makes even more sense when we think of sad movies. Sad music may give our feelings a backtrack or a soundtrack or a language. Movies give us comfort and they give us the structure of a story. In all sad movies, Mali and Me, Shinless, La Land, you know, there is a beginning. There is often a relationship, there's a loss, there's a reaction and there's an end. It's extremely neat.
这一切都没有现实生活的影响。如果歌曲确实符合某人正在经历的情况，它实际上为那种感觉提供了一个容器。你知道，我听那首悲伤的歌。我在歌长的时间里感到悲伤。歌曲结束了。悲伤也可能结束了。当我们想到悲伤的电影时，这更有意义。悲伤的音乐可能给我们的感觉一个背景、一个原声带或一种语言。电影给我们安慰，给我们故事的结构。在所有悲伤的电影中，《马利与我》、《辛德勒的名单》、《爱乐之城》，你知道，有一个开始。通常有一段关系，有失去，有反应，然后有一个结局。它非常整洁。
And by the end, things are wrapped up. Real sadness is really that way. In real life, we don't know why somebody left. We don't know what somebody's thinking, whether we're ever going to see them again, what the lesson was. We don't know when we're supposed to move on. Movies compress emotional experiences into a story that we can understand from beginning to end. And if there's one thing the human mind loves, it's that kind of certainty. and structure. Hence, why we leave the cinema or we finish a movie and we're crying in bed and it feels, it feels good, it feels nice. There is also an aesthetic component as well. Specifically, we're moving back to music, sorry, movies to music, back to music. Music makes sadness feel beautiful
到最后，事情都解决了。真正的悲伤很少是那样的。在现实生活中，我们不知道为什么有人离开。我们不知道某人在想什么，我们是否还会再见到他们，教训是什么。我们不知道什么时候该继续前进。电影将情感体验压缩成一个我们可以从头到尾理解的故事。如果人类思维喜欢一件事，那就是那种确定性和结构。因此，为什么我们离开电影院或看完电影后在床上哭泣，感觉很好，感觉不错。还有一个审美成分。具体来说，我们回到音乐，抱歉，电影到音乐，回到音乐。音乐让悲伤感觉很美，
rather than just miserable because it is wrapped up in this nice, wonderful, delightful packaging with somebody who probably has a beautiful voice. Another study from 2015, examiner. into this further and basically found that often it's the aesthetic experience of music, which is pleasurable, that mixes with the emotional experience of sadness, which isn't, and it creates something in the middle. And it's what we would call appreciation. Some people might call it judgment, but I call it appreciation. And it's a much gentler feeling. It's much gentler than the full force of sadness. The other thing is that when we're up against a really big, awful maybe uncomfortable situation or emotion, sometimes we just don't want happiness that isn't
而不是仅仅感到痛苦，因为它被包裹在这种美好、美妙、令人愉悦的包装中，由一个可能拥有美妙嗓音的人演唱。2015年的另一项研究对此进行了进一步审查，基本上发现，通常是音乐的审美体验（这是令人愉悦的）与悲伤的情感体验（这并不令人愉悦）混合在一起，在中间创造了一些东西。这就是我们所说的“欣赏”。有些人可能称之为判断，但我称之为欣赏。这是一种更温和的感觉。它比悲伤的全部力量要温和得多。另一件事是，当我们面对一个非常大、糟糕、可能不舒服的情况或情绪时，有时我们只是不想要快乐，
going to be really helpful right now because it feels too inaccessible. Instead, we want to go further in. We want some emotional depth. We want some emotional clarity maybe. We just want to feel really moved. We want to feel everything, nostalgic, tender, reflective, heartbroken, maybe grateful all at once. And music and movies is an incredibly safe way of creating that experience. because eventually the song will end. It's going to end. But it's also nice knowing that somebody else had to feel as bad as we did to make that art. Like they had to feel so bad, bad enough that they would make music that we are relating to
因为现在感觉太遥不可及了。相反，我们想深入进去。我们想要一些情感深度。我们可能想要一些情感清晰度。我们只是想感到真正被打动。我们想感受一切，怀旧、温柔、反思、心碎，也许同时感到感激。音乐和电影是一种创造这种体验的极其安全的方式。因为最终歌曲会结束。它会结束的。但知道别人必须像我们一样感到糟糕才能创作出那种艺术，这也很好。就像他们必须感到如此糟糕，糟糕到足以创作出我们能产生共鸣的音乐，
and therefore we feel less alone. And sometimes that's the biggest comfort. I really do think that the biggest comfort when you're sad or heartbroken is knowing that you are not the only person who's ever lived through this and you will survive. So this also points to something else happening when we do. choose sad music, especially when we're already sad. Seems counterintuitive. I think normally we think about emotional regulation as changing the emotion, taking us away from sadness. So if you're sad, put on something happy. If you're anxious, put on something calm. If you're angry, put on something
因此我们感到不那么孤独。有时那是最大的安慰。我真的认为，当你悲伤或心碎时，最大的安慰是知道你不是唯一经历过这一切的人，而且你会活下来。所以这也指向了当我们选择悲伤音乐时发生的另一件事，尤其是当我们已经悲伤时。这看起来违反直觉。我认为通常我们认为情绪调节是改变情绪，让我们远离悲伤。所以如果你悲伤，听点快乐的。如果你焦虑，听点平静的。如果你生气，听点
peaceful. You know, take your feeling. Find the direct opposite. Pursue that. But humans don't always regulate emotion by trying to feel better. We also regulate emotion by trying to feel understood and trying to have a story for our emotion and trying to put our feeling in its correct spot, if that makes sense. We want to give our feeling context in order to process it. We also want emotional validation. That's how we process emotion. And music allows us to do that. One 2020 paper by the researchers, Arons and Stangler, suggests that why we listen to sad music is because we want to feel like our emotions are real. And by staying in our sadness, by making our sadness bigger so that we feel the emotion more, it means that it also feels more
平和的。你知道，接受你的感觉。找到直接的对立面。追求那个。但人类并不总是通过试图感觉更好来调节情绪。我们也通过试图感到被理解、试图为我们的情绪找到一个故事、试图把我们的感觉放在正确的位置来调节情绪，如果这有意义的话。我们想给我们的感觉提供背景以便处理它。我们也想要情感验证。这就是我们处理情绪的方式。音乐允许我们这样做。研究人员Arons和Stangler在2020年的一篇论文中建议，我们听悲伤音乐的原因是因为我们想感觉我们的情绪是真实的。通过停留在悲伤中，通过让悲伤变大，这样我们就能更多地感受到这种情绪，这意味着它也感觉更
legitimate, that we deserve to be feeling this because we feel it so intensely. To explain this a little bit more, you know, if sadness is just lingering, sometimes it feels a bit silly, it doesn't feel valid. But if sadness feels all consuming and it's loud and it's massive and we really like put fuel on the fire, it feels less silly in the first place. It allows for a little bit more emotional validation. We're very complex creatures, but basically why we pursue sad, art, sad, books, sad, music, whatever, especially when we're already feeling sad, is put simply because it gives that feeling a distinct shape.
合法，我们理应感受到这一点，因为我们感受得如此强烈。为了进一步解释这一点，你知道，如果悲伤只是挥之不去，有时感觉有点傻，感觉不成立。但如果悲伤感觉是吞噬一切的，而且它很响亮、很巨大，我们真的像是在火上浇油，它在第一时间感觉就不那么傻了。它允许更多的情感验证。我们是非常复杂的生物，但基本上我们追求悲伤的艺术、悲伤的书籍、悲伤的音乐等的原因，尤其是当我们已经感到悲伤时，简单来说是因为它给了那种感觉一个独特的形状。
And it gives it a distinct form and it validates it in a way that allows us to make sense of it and therefore process the feeling or at least feel a little bit good about the feeling whilst also feeling bad about it. There is another explanation here. It is perhaps my favorite, and that is the catharsis explanation. And I think it's probably the one that you have heard of before. So we're going to take a short break here. When we return, let's talk about it and let's talk further about why we love to be sad. Stay with us. Get Bell, Pure Fiber Internet with Crave, Netflix, and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit.
它给了它一个独特的形态，并以一种允许我们理解它并因此处理这种感觉的方式验证了它，或者至少在对这种感觉感到糟糕的同时，对这种感觉感觉良好。这里还有另一种解释。它可能是我最喜欢的，那就是“宣泄”解释。我想这可能是你以前听说过的。所以我们在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们谈谈它，并进一步谈谈为什么我们喜欢悲伤。和我们在一起。获取Bell纯光纤互联网，包含Crave、Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94加元起。互联网价格保证两年，需签订两年合约并使用自动付款优惠。
Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita. trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us.
访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接即一切。在新的播客节目《Solita》中，我们分享女性独自旅行的真实混乱经历。我可以等四个小时坐下一班巴士，或者这个陌生男人提议让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是Julie Pinero，我独自旅行，因为这是一个难得的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代怜悯。每次我试图独处时，我都会遇到人，他们会说，你对我们笑了。
Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeartR. Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have
这里没多少人笑。当你独处时，你对世界的本来面目最敏感，而不是别人卖给你的关于它的谎言。这可以是一段你突破极限、改变主意或唤醒新自我的时光。所以无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是太紧张而不敢预订第一次旅行，我希望你在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Solita》。当我14岁时，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我活了下来，我花了一生时间探索其他人是如何在应该
destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive.
摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是Elizabeth Smart，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边那个低沉、嘲弄的声音说，闭嘴，什么都别说。每周我都和经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始觉得床尾有人，我就开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。但这些不是关于他们被夺走了什么的故事。这是关于为了活下来需要付出什么的故事。
Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo, and every week we're connecting the dots. between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From best-selling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments,
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Elizabeth Smart的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《Prose Society》，每周一期的播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是思想女儿、流行文化痴迷者和任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《Love Island》值得同等讨论的人的群聊。我是Eli Rallo，每周我们都在连接
nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right, place. Listen to pro society on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. Middle School is a different world than the one we grew up in. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spend real time on it in our surviving middle school run, bringing in a child psychologist
书籍、互联网和每个人都无法停止讨论的话题之间的点。我得查查这个故事。我着迷了。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的书评创作者到最新的流行文化时刻，
and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own to talk about what's really going on with our kids right now. literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all this same time. We got into group chats and gaming, friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. There's belonging. You could think of belonging as I can be myself and I can still be accepted.
没有什么是不可以谈论的。就像如果你能把一些真实的信息隐藏在引人入胜的角色中，那这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度解析、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢思考太多的读者社区，你都来对地方了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Prose Society》。书页间见。大约11岁时，至少70%的孩子有手机。初中是一个与我们成长时期完全不同的世界。我是Joy博士，这是《黑人女孩疗法》。我们在“幸存初中”系列中投入了真正的时间，请来了一位儿童心理学家
And then there's fitting in. Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers, sitting down with therapy. this cure gains on Black fatherhood and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage. You don't have on shorts, so you can't do flips, you have on the dressy, up across your legs. That's the range of this run,
和一位正在抚养两个黑人女儿的精神科医生，谈谈我们孩子现在到底在经历什么。字面上是生理、神经和心理上的混乱同时发生。我们讨论了群聊和游戏、友谊和欺凌，以及如何区分健康的监控和那种侵蚀信任的监视。有归属感。你可以把归属感理解为“我可以做我自己，我仍然可以被接受”。
from screen time to identity to the father's doing the work at home. We have to get off her device, but the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their life to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers
然后是“融入”。融入意味着我必须改变我是谁，以避免被拒绝。然后我们将对话转向父亲，坐下来与《黑人女孩疗法》谈论黑人父亲身份，以及在这个阶段抚养女儿意味着什么。你没穿短裤，所以你不能做后空翻，你穿的是裙子，双腿交叉。这就是这个系列的范围，
thinking about exactly this. I'm Dr. Joy. to therapy for black girls on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcast so there's another thing that deliberately making ourselves feel sad gives us and that is a release it gives us a psychological and emotional outlet now this is probably the oldest and most ancient explanation in this episode one that has existed literally before psychology even existed before any of this stuff about theories and evidence and science it came from Aristotle, and he famously used the concept of catharsis when discussing Greek tragedy,
从屏幕时间到身份，再到在家中努力的父亲。我们必须让她离开设备，但现实是，外面有很多生活，我们作为他们生活中的成年人，不希望你们错过。这就是我们的“幸存初中”系列。由那些职业生涯都在
and he proposed that by watching tragic stories this somehow purges or purifies our own emotions, like pity, fear, sadness, all those things. What he really meant when he said that, we still don't really know, but basically in simple English, Aristotle believed, watching sad stuff lets us get the messy stuff out. Now, this popular model of catharsis often imagines emotions almost like you're like shaking a bottle. It's like pressure inside this container. And if something bad happens, something sad happens, like it builds and builds and builds unless you let something out, unless you do something about it.
思考这个问题的人带给你。我是Joy博士。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《黑人女孩疗法》。所以，故意让自己感到悲伤还能给我们带来另一件事，那就是释放。它给了我们一个心理和情感的出口。现在，这可能是本集中最古老、最原始的解释，一个在心理学存在之前，在所有关于理论、证据和科学的东西存在之前就存在的东西。它来自亚里士多德，他在讨论希腊悲剧时著名地使用了“宣泄”的概念，
And if you don't, it's going to explode. It's going to explode over everyone you love, over everyone around you. It's going to be messy if you don't have a release. This is an incredibly intuitive idea. And it makes a lot of sense, but modern psychology would now tell us that it's probably a bit too simplistic. For starters, your emotions aren't physical substances, right? They're not like accumulating somewhere in the body waiting to be drained. There's not some limit that we all hit. And when we hit it, we either have to release it and go back to zero or we explode. It's a bit more complex.
他提出，通过观看悲剧故事，这以某种方式净化了我们自己的情绪，比如怜悯、恐惧、悲伤，所有这些东西。当他说这话时，他真正指的是什么，我们仍然不太清楚，但基本上用简单的英语来说，亚里士多德认为，观看悲伤的东西让我们把混乱的东西排解出来。现在，这种流行的宣泄模式通常把情绪想象成你像在摇晃一个瓶子。它就像这个容器里的压力。如果发生了坏事，发生了悲伤的事，它就会不断积累，除非你让它释放出来，除非你对此做点什么。
You know, expressing an emotion might not always actually help you feel better. There's a lot of research about this with anger, especially a recent paper that was published, I think just a year in the Social Psychology Bulletin where they essentially said sometimes venting, sometimes ranting, sometimes letting anger out actually makes the emotion worse rather than eliminating it. And we kind of see this for sadness and other things as well. It's not that it's like releasing it and taking you back down to zero. It's not that the sadness is leaving your body literally, and that's why you feel. good, it's more likely that when you get to feel this way, you finally feel safe.
如果你不这样做，它就会爆炸。它会在你爱的每个人、你周围的每个人身上爆炸。如果你没有一个释放渠道，那将会是一团糟。这是一个非常直观的想法。它很有道理，但现代心理学现在会告诉我们，它可能有点太简单了。首先，你的情绪不是物质实体，对吧？它们不像是在身体的某个地方积累，等待被排干。我们所有人都没有达到某种极限。当我们达到极限时，我们要么必须释放它并回到零，要么我们就会爆炸。它更复杂一些。
You know, if we only feel sad when we let ourselves feel sad, we'll probably do it when we feel safest to do so. So that feeling of finally feeling safe mixes with the feeling of catharsis and also mixes with the end of emotional suppression. The end of emotional suppression is a critical part of this because it also means the end of all of this effort that's required to keep these big and heavy feelings in. Suppressing your feelings, it's not the absence of the feeling. It's not like it's not there at all. It's the existence of one very big feeling or many feelings that you are actively having to monitor. You are actively having to push down. And that takes a lot of mental and cognitive energy, a lot. And so when you stop doing that, yes, there is
你知道，表达一种情绪可能并不总是能让你感觉更好。关于愤怒有很多研究，尤其是最近发表的一篇论文，我想就在《社会心理学公报》上，他们基本上说有时发泄、有时咆哮、有时释放愤怒实际上会让情绪变得更糟，而不是消除它。我们对悲伤和其他事情也看到了这一点。并不是说它像释放它并让你回到零。并不是说悲伤真的离开了你的身体，这就是为什么你感觉
relief, there might be release, but also suddenly all these attentional and cognitive resources suddenly become available to you that were previously preoccupied with keeping everything down. All these resources come back online because they're not preoccupied with this other job. And now that you've got a bit of your attention back, a bit of your cognitive flexibility back, you now have the ability to notice all the good stuff as well, to be present, to handle other things that needed taking care of. all of that also makes us feel better. Hence why letting yourself feel sad has a paradoxical effect of also letting yourself feel happy because suddenly you're not just only bothered with not feeling this
良好，更有可能的是，当你能这样感受时，你终于感到安全了。所以那种终于感到安全的感觉与宣泄的感觉混合在一起，也与情感压抑的结束混合在一起。情感压抑的结束是其中的关键部分，因为它也意味着结束了所有为了保持这些巨大而沉重的感觉而需要的努力。压抑你的感觉，并不是感觉的缺失。并不是说它根本不存在。它是你必须主动监控的一种非常大的感觉或多种感觉的存在。你必须主动地压制它。这需要大量的心理和认知能量，非常多。所以当你停止这样做时，是的，有
way, not feeling this way, not feeling this way, you're allowed to kind of sit in the emotional complexity a little bit more, which means also letting happiness come in also. This is where I think the distinction between sadness and suffering from earlier becomes really important. And I know I talked about it a lot, but it's going to come back and hear one more time. Often the most painful part of an emotion isn't simply the primary emotion itself. It's everything that we layer on top of it. I'm sad, but I shouldn't be sad because if I get any sadder, it's going to get worse and then I'm going to lose control. You know, I'm upset about this, but people have bigger problems. So if I keep worrying about it, I'm going to be selfish. You're not simply allowing yourself to experience sadness.
缓解，可能会有释放，但突然间，所有这些以前被占用在压制一切的注意力资源和认知资源突然对你可用了。所有这些资源都重新上线了，因为它们不再被这项其他工作所占据。现在你已经恢复了一点注意力，一点认知灵活性，你现在有能力注意到所有好的东西，能够活在当下，处理其他需要照顾的事情。所有这些也让我们感觉更好。因此，为什么让自己感到悲伤有一种悖论效应，即也让自己感到快乐，因为突然间你不仅仅是被“不感觉这样”所困扰，
you're experiencing sadness plus shame, sadness plus anxiety, sadness plus self-criticism, and it becomes very complex and confusing. This is where we need to talk about the value of that thing we mentioned in the introduction, which is emo diversity, specifically why some of the most intelligent and well-adjusted people you know know that sadness needs to be readily expressed if they want to function and have their best lives. So emo diversity is essentially, how do I explain this? It's like the variety and relative abundance of emotions that make up your emotional life. The best way to describe it is about, it's in comparison to biodiversity, but for like your
“不感觉这样，不感觉这样”，你被允许在情感复杂性中多坐一会儿，这意味着也让快乐进来。这就是我认为早先提到的悲伤和受苦之间的区别变得非常重要的地方。我知道我谈了很多，但它会回来，在这里再出现一次。通常，一种情绪中最痛苦的部分不仅仅是原始情绪本身。它是我们叠加在它上面的所有东西。我很悲伤，但我本不应该悲伤，因为如果我变得更悲伤，情况会变得更糟，然后我会失去控制。你知道，我对此感到不安，但人们有更大的问题。所以如果我继续担心它，我会变得自私。你不仅仅是允许自己体验悲伤，
internal world. So like a really healthy natural ecosystem doesn't just contain one species, even if that species is really beautiful, right? It contains a lot of different species that perform a lot of different roles. including species that we don't really like, like flies or ants or bugs or pests, they are just as necessary as the butterflies and the puppies and the ponies, even though those ones seem more beautiful. You need both for the ecosystem to function if you get my metaphor.
你正在体验悲伤加羞耻，悲伤加焦虑，悲伤加自我批评，它变得非常复杂和混乱。这就是我们需要谈论我们在引言中提到的那个东西的价值，即“情绪多样性”，特别是为什么你认识的一些最聪明、最适应良好的人知道，如果他们想发挥作用并过上最好的生活，悲伤需要随时表达出来。所以情绪多样性本质上是，我该怎么解释呢？它就像构成你情感生活的各种情绪的种类和相对丰度。描述它的最好方式是，它与生物多样性相比，但对于你的
You need sadness, you need happiness, you need all the things. One of the most influential studies on this comes from a psychologist called Jordie Quaback and him and his colleagues, they conducted these two big studies in 2014. And when I say big, these studies had 37,000 people in them. And what they found was that people who reported experiencing a greater variety of emotions tended to report better mental and physical health, including lower levels of depression, including fewer visits to the hospital. Emo diversity predicted these outcomes above and beyond happiness. So when they asked people, how often do you experience happiness? And somebody said, oh, I experience it a lot. That wasn't going to
内心世界。所以一个非常健康的自然生态系统不仅仅包含一个物种，即使那个物种真的很美，对吧？它包含许多执行许多不同角色的不同物种。包括我们不太喜欢的物种，比如苍蝇或蚂蚁或虫子或害虫，它们和蝴蝶、小狗和小马一样必要，尽管那些看起来更美。如果你明白我的比喻，你需要两者才能使生态系统发挥作用。
predict whether they were actually happy. If you said to somebody, how often do you feel a variety of emotion? Well, I feel it a lot. That was going to predict a well-rounded life. I want to be really precise here, because the findings do not mean that sadness is the secret to mental health or stopping you from getting sick and you should be deliberately ruining one day a week as part of a healthy life protocol. These studies were correlational, but what they did basically show evidence for was that emotional diversity directly causes better health for a couple of reasons. A, greater emotional acceptance meant less force. Basically, you are better able to flow with your emotions and you just have greater acceptance in life. Therefore, those emotions feel less stressful when you do
你需要悲伤，你需要快乐，你需要所有的东西。关于这一点最有影响力的研究之一来自一位名叫Jordie Quaback的心理学家，他和他的同事在2014年进行了这两项大型研究。当我说大型时，这些研究有37,000人参与。他们发现，报告体验到更多种类情绪的人往往报告有更好的心理和身体健康，包括更低的抑郁水平，包括更少的医院就诊次数。情绪多样性预测了这些结果，超越了快乐。所以当他们问人们，“你多久体验一次快乐？”有人说，“哦，我经常体验它。”那并不能
experience them and they actually pass sooner because if you're not fearful of them, you'll actually give them space that they need to exist and to move through what they need to move through. Two, emo diversity seems to give us greater coping skills. You know, you don't learn to cope if you don't let yourself experience. And so when emotions do get really unmanageable, if you don't have any skills, you're pretty screwed. And three is contrast. Now, this is probably the most important concept in this entire episode and one that I've already alluded to. But things, just feel better when you have something to compare them to. More specifically, things feel better when you know what it's like to not have them. You know, if we were to just be happy all the
去体验它们，它们反而会更快过去，因为如果你不害怕它们，你实际上是给了它们存在的空间，让它们经历它们需要经历的过程。第二，情绪多样性似乎能赋予我们更强的应对能力。你知道，如果你不让自己去体验，你就学不会应对。所以当情绪变得真正难以驾驭时，如果你没有任何技巧，你就彻底完蛋了。第三是对比。这可能是整集节目中最重要的概念，也是我之前已经提到过的。但是，当你有了可以比较的对象时，事情感觉会更好。更具体地说，当你了解没有这些东西是什么感觉时，事情感觉会更好。你知道，如果我们只是快乐，
time, our brains would get really used to that. And all that pleasure and happiness would actually not feel as great. It would feel a lot less good overall. There's a term for this in psychology. It's known as hedonic adaptation. And it basically says that after a while, the emotional intensity of even something really good tends to fade as we become accustomed to it. So if you want a million dollars tomorrow, you would be over the moon. You would literally not know what to do with yourself. If you won a million dollars the day after that, you'd probably also feel really, really good in the day after that and the day after that. But what about day three? On day 300, I don't know if you'd be as excited as you were on day one.
一直快乐，我们的大脑就会对此习以为常。所有的快乐和幸福感实际上就不会感觉那么强烈了。总的来说，感觉会差很多。心理学中有一个术语，叫做享乐适应。它基本上是说，过了一段时间后，即使是非常好的事情，其情绪强度也会随着我们习惯它而趋于减弱。所以如果你明天得到一百万美元，你会欣喜若狂。你简直不知道该怎么办才好。如果你在后一天又赢了一百万美元，你可能也会感觉非常好，再后一天也是如此。但第三天呢？到了第300天，我不知道你是否还会像第一天那样兴奋。
The same way we can adapt to hard things, we also adapt to good things as well. And this is why emo diversity and also sadness has a vital function, because it provides appreciation and nuance and contrast to life. There is no up without down. And even if that was its only role, if sadness was to just be a contrast to happiness as a way to make happiness brighter, it would still be important, but there is a little bit more to it. Beyond contrast, sadness also feels good because it gives our life meaning. Sadness is a natural reaction to things that are just
就像我们能适应困难的事情一样，我们也能适应好的事情。这就是为什么情绪多样性以及悲伤具有至关重要的功能，因为它为生活提供了欣赏、细微差别和对比。没有低谷就没有高峰。即使这只是它的唯一作用，如果悲伤仅仅是作为快乐的对比，作为一种让快乐更明亮的方式，它仍然很重要，但它还有更多的意义。除了对比之外，悲伤也感觉很好，因为它赋予了我们生活意义。悲伤是对那些事情的自然反应，仅仅是因为
sad because we cared about them a lot. It's sad to say goodbye to someone or to a pet or to close a certain chapter in your life. It's really sad when you are let down by a job or a friend or when you really wanted an opportunity and you didn't get it. And your sadness in these moments is an indication of how much something really meant. And I always think as deep as you can grieve and as deep as you can be frustrated and heartbroken and betrayed is about as deep as you can love and about as deep as you can be passionate and appreciate what you do have. Sadness provides that. It provides meaning by showing you what you really care about. Plus, let's just be honest, sometimes self-pity feels really nice because for once you get
悲伤，因为我们非常在意它们。向某人、宠物告别，或者结束生命中的某个篇章，这很令人悲伤。当你被工作或朋友辜负，或者当你非常想要一个机会却没得到时，这真的很令人悲伤。你在这些时刻的悲伤表明了某件事对你有多重要。我一直认为，你悲伤的深度、沮丧和心碎的深度、被背叛的深度，大约就是你爱的深度，也是你充满激情和珍惜你所拥有的东西的深度。悲伤提供了这一点。它通过向你展示你真正关心什么来提供意义。另外，说实话，有时候自怜感觉真的很好，因为你终于可以
to be the center of the universe. You didn't get the job, your boyfriend broke up with you, you just get to feel like for a moment, you know, yeah, I am the saddest person in the world right now. I do have the worst luck. Yeah, nobody has it as hard as me. Now, is that true? Probably not. But just for a brief second, our ego gets to just.
成为宇宙的中心。你没得到那份工作，男朋友和你分手了，你只是可以暂时感觉一下，你知道，是的，我现在是世界上最悲伤的人。我的运气确实是最差的。是的，没有人像我这么惨。现在，这是真的吗？可能不是。但就在那一瞬间，我们的自我可以
let loose against all its better judgment and against all of our typical shame for doing so and for feeling self-pity, it just lets to have that. It's like a cheat meal for our self-awareness. We just get to feel really, really shit. And something you may not know is that self-pity doesn't just feel pleasurable in the moment. It also makes you a better person. Literally, feeling self-pity, there have been quite a few articles about this, including a very good one by this psychologist called Nick Wignall. And he essentially says self-pity reminds us to be empathetic. It motivates us to be compassionate.
不顾一切理智，不顾我们通常因这样做和感到自怜而产生的羞耻感，它只是让这种感觉存在。这就像是我们自我意识的“欺骗餐”。我们只是感觉真的很糟糕。你可能不知道的是，自怜不仅在当下感觉愉悦，它还能让你成为一个更好的人。实际上，关于自怜，已经有不少文章讨论过，包括心理学家尼克·威格纳尔写的一篇非常好的文章。他基本上说，自怜提醒我们要有同理心。它激励我们要有同情心。
It inspires us to be curious. It makes us more creative. I think the reason why is because knowing how rotten it feels to be lonely or to get really, really let down by something and really going deep into the crevices of that feeling means that you can relate more when somebody else comes to you and says, I felt the same way, or I'm having this similar feeling. We have these very special neurons in our brain. They're called mirror neurons, and scientists actually believe that these cells are what
它激发我们要有好奇心。它让我们更有创造力。我认为原因在于，了解孤独或被某事深深辜负的感觉有多糟糕，并真正深入到那种感觉的缝隙中，意味着当别人来找你说“我有过同样的感受”或“我有类似的感受”时，你能产生更多的共鸣。我们大脑中有这些非常特殊的神经元。它们被称为镜像神经元，科学家们实际上认为这些细胞是
allow us to feel what others feel, and they are the neural basis for empathy. The only way, though, that these neural pathways are built or can be primed is if we experience the emotions for ourselves. We do not have the capacity to be as deeply empathetic unless we experience it firsthand. and can therefore look at somebody else and say, I know exactly where I can feel that in your body, in my body. So your sadness has a pro-social function in that allows you to perhaps be a better friend, to be a better sibling, to be a better colleague, child. Now, that as a secondary benefit, feels pretty nice. There is something really fulfilling about knowing exactly what
让我们能够感受他人所感受到的东西，它们是同理心的神经基础。然而，这些神经通路被建立或被激活的唯一途径，就是我们亲自体验这些情绪。除非我们亲身经历，否则我们没有能力产生如此深刻的同理心。因此，我们可以看着别人说：“我知道我在你的身体里，在我的身体里，哪里能感受到那种感觉。”所以你的悲伤具有亲社会功能，因为它让你可能成为一个更好的朋友、更好的兄弟姐妹、更好的同事、孩子。现在，作为次要的好处，这感觉相当不错。知道确切地
words of support somebody needs to hear during a hard time, because those are the words that you would have wanted to hear. And it is a really nice feeling, really, really nice to realize that you help somebody and that you could sit with somebody in a hard time and make them feel better. And I know that that is not a direct positive association of sadness. And I know that's not why sadness feels great in the moment. But I do think it counts nonetheless. And just to make one final point on this, one final study, according to some research from Berkeley, sadness may also help you become more emotionally intelligent overall in a very similar, in a similar way. So in these experiments, researchers induced either feelings of happiness or
在困难时期某人需要听到什么样的支持话语，这确实有一种成就感，因为那些正是你当时想听到的话。意识到你帮助了某人，并且你可以在困难时期陪伴某人，让他们感觉更好，这是一种非常好的感觉，真的非常好。我知道这不是悲伤的直接积极关联。我也知道这不是悲伤在当下感觉良好的原因。但我确实认为它仍然很重要。关于这一点，最后再提一点，一项来自伯克利的最新研究表明，悲伤也可能在类似的方式下帮助你整体上变得更具情绪智力。在这些实验中，研究人员诱导了快乐或
sadness into kind of like a group of students, a group of participants. And then they asked them, they asked them to detect deception, detect deception in videotaped statements of people being accused of theft. Now, some of them were guilty, some of them weren't, some of them admitted it, some of them didn't. Participants who were made to feel sad were more likely to make a correct judgment. They were better able to detect whether somebody was deceptive or truthful. They had a higher EQ for the moment. And I think this is the final resounding truth about sadness. It feels really awful at times. But being able to tap into that state and feel it when you need gives you access to the full depth of human emotion and the full depth of the human experience.
悲伤的情绪进入一组学生、一组参与者中。然后他们要求他们检测欺骗，检测被指控盗窃的人在录像陈述中的欺骗行为。现在，有些人是有罪的，有些人没有，有些人承认了，有些人没有。被诱导感到悲伤的参与者更有可能做出正确的判断。他们能更好地检测出某人是在撒谎还是在说真话。他们在那一刻有更高的情商。我认为这是关于悲伤的最终响亮的真理。它有时感觉真的很糟糕。但能够利用那种状态并在需要时感受它，让你能够接触到人类情感的全部深度和人类体验的全部深度。
This is truly meaningful. It's truly expansive and I truly think it's helpful at times compared to somebody who kind of just ropes off this part of themselves and never feels sad or only feels sad when the feeling is so large that it's hard to ignore and therefore never gets to feel like there's a benefit. So to summarize this episode, I want to just quickly say, I am not saying run full speed a head towards your sadness, bathe in your sadness, indulge in your sadness, constantly, live in your sadness. But sadness isn't this big evil monster in the emotional closet. For starters, it's different to suffering. It actually feels really nice at times. Some would say even pleasurable. And it also feels fulfilling to kind of grow deeper into your emotional state.
这是真正有意义的。它是真正广阔的，我真的认为它有时是有帮助的，相比于那些把这部分自己封锁起来，从不感到悲伤，或者只有在感觉大到无法忽视时才感到悲伤，因此永远无法感受到它的好处的人。所以总结这一集，我想快速说一下，我不是说让你全速冲向你的悲伤，沉浸在你的悲伤中，放纵你的悲伤，一直生活在你的悲伤中。但悲伤并不是情绪壁橱里那个巨大的邪恶怪物。首先，它与痛苦不同。它有时实际上感觉非常好。有些人甚至会说它是愉悦的。而且深入到你的情绪状态中也感觉很充实。
It also connects you to a deeper reality about being human. And it provides emotional catharsis. it allows you to connect deeper with art. And it also provides that contrast that we know is so important. It just gives life more texture and flavor compared to just being happy and fine and calm all the time. And that my friends is the beauty of this emotion, the beauty of sadness. It gives you so much more than I think we realize. Even if, like, and I think that's why you got to let, I know I said don't indulge in it,
它还将你与关于身为人类的更深层现实联系起来。它提供了情绪宣泄。它让你与艺术建立更深层的联系。它还提供了我们所知道的非常重要的对比。与一直快乐、安好、平静相比，它只是给了生活更多的质感和风味。我的朋友们，这就是这种情绪的美，悲伤的美。它给你的比我认为我们意识到的要多得多。即使，就像，我认为这就是为什么你必须让，我知道我说过不要沉溺于它，
but sometimes you've got to let yourself because there is something really. really special about listening to a really sad song and being like nothing and nobody has got me the way that this song does in this moment. Like whoever wrote this song could be my soulmate. And being able to tap into that shared humanity through your sadness, even if you don't realize it in the moment, I think it feels pretty good. And I think it feels a little bit enjoyable. So I hope this episode has allowed you to reframe this experience.
但有时你必须让自己去感受，因为听一首非常悲伤的歌，感觉“没有任何人和事能像这首歌此刻这样触动我”，这确实是非常、非常特别的。就像写这首歌的人可能是我的灵魂伴侣。能够通过你的悲伤触及那种共同的人性，即使你在当下没有意识到，我认为这感觉相当不错。而且我认为这感觉有点令人享受。所以我希望这一集能让你重新审视这种体验。
especially if you're going through a particularly tough season at the moment or you just need a reminder that it's okay to not be happy and not beat and jovial all the time. I think that's it for me, actually. So if you enjoyed this episode, remember to subscribe. Remember to follow along wherever you are listening. Check out this episode and all about other episodes on Netflix. It is the number one thing you can do to help us and help support the psychology of your 20s. You can also follow us on Instagram or Substack if you want more psychology, research and studies direct to your email once a week. If you've made it this far and you're still listening and you're listening on Spotify,
特别是如果你目前正经历一个特别艰难的时期，或者你只是需要一个提醒，即不快乐、不总是兴高采烈也没关系。我想这就是我要说的了。所以如果你喜欢这一集，记得订阅。记得在你收听的地方关注我们。在Netflix上查看这一集和我们所有的其他剧集。这是你能做的帮助我们并支持《你的20岁心理学》的第一件事。如果你想要每周直接发送到你邮箱的更多心理学研究和学习，你也可以在Instagram或Substack上关注我们。如果你已经看到这里，并且你还在听，而且你是在Spotify上收听，
hello, how you going? Leave a little comment down below. What is your favorite all-time sad movie or sad song? And I'm going to put together a little list and post it on Instagram. Maybe I'll make a little playlist for us to all listen to. But yeah, leave a comment down below. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon.
你好，你好吗？在下面留个小评论。你最喜欢的悲伤电影或悲伤歌曲是什么？我会整理一个小列表并发布在Instagram上。也许我会制作一个小播放列表供我们大家收听。但是是的，在下面留个评论。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, Black Literature.
在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享作为女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时等下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙提议让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“是”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代怜悯。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Solita》。是否存在一种针对文学的流行病？更具体地说，针对黑人文学。
I'm Jack Quist-Pice Thomas, and on this season of the Black-Lit podcast, we're outside asking why. They don't want a whole bunch of little Ella bakers, Malcolm Waxes and Martin Luther King's running around. And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black Reading Month, the only real question is, What are you reading next? Listen to Black Lit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. What up, y'all, this your main man, Memphis Bleak right here.
我是杰克·奎斯特-派斯·托马斯，在这一季的《Black-Lit》播客中，我们走出来询问原因。他们不希望有一大堆像埃拉·贝克、马尔科姆·X和马丁·路德·金那样的人到处跑。当你观察许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，唯一真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听来自Black Effect Podcast Network的《Black Lit》。大家好，我是你们的主力，孟菲斯·布里克。
Host of that Rock Solid podcast. And each week, we bring in you exclusive looks inside music. Everything happening inside the culture. Some of the best conversations were the biggest names in the game. You had a little bit more pressure to be good. And they didn't care if you as a girl. Like, you wasn't getting no points if you know. Not trash. You better be not just good. You better be great.
《Rock Solid》播客的主持人。每周，我们都会带你深入了解音乐。文化中发生的一切。一些最棒的对话是与业内最大牌的人物进行的。你会有更大的压力去表现出色。他们不在乎你是不是女孩。就像，如果你知道的话，你得不到任何分数。不是垃圾。你最好不仅要好。你最好要伟大。
Listen to Rock Solid on Black Effect Podcast Network, iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you streamed podcast. Hey there, everybody. Amy Robach and TJ Holmes here from the Amy and TJ podcast. A lot of times, the story of the day is what we're all talking about and buzzing about. And yes, sometimes it's Love Island and sometimes it's Serena Robes. Coming back to the U.S. Open, sometimes it's obsession. And Spider-Man making box office history. Hopefully, Rose, people get our point. Listen to Amy and T.J. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you listen to podcasts.
在Black Effect Podcast Network、iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你流媒体播放播客的地方收听《Rock Solid》。嘿，大家好。我是来自《Amy and TJ》播客的艾米·罗巴赫和TJ·霍姆斯。很多时候，当天的故事是我们大家都在谈论和热议的话题。是的，有时是《恋爱岛》，有时是塞雷娜·威廉姆斯回到美国公开赛，有时是痴迷。还有蜘蛛侠创造票房历史。希望，罗斯，人们明白我们的意思。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Amy and T.J.》。
Let's go! The countdown is on to the most talked-about music festival on the planet. Let's go crazy. Our I-Heart Radio Music Festival. Presented by Capital One, September 18th and 19th at T-Mobile Arena, Las Vegas. 15 artists Two nights One Stage
我们走吧！倒计时开始了，迎接地球上最受关注的音乐节。让我们疯狂吧。我们的iHeart Radio音乐节。由Capital One呈现，9月18日和19日在拉斯维加斯T-Mobile体育馆举行。15位艺人，两个夜晚，一个舞台
Listen on I Heart Radio stations across the country And stream it live on Disney Plus and Hulu BTS Benz and Boone Cardi B Sierra
在全国的iHeart Radio电台上收听，并在Disney Plus和Hulu上直播。BTS、Benz和Boone、Cardi B、Ciara
Goo Goo Goo Doll Kenny Chesby Ariel Lanie Wilson La Cereofim Major Laser Mews Snoop Dog
Goo Goo Dolls、Kenny Chesney、Ariana、Lanie Wilson、LE SSERAFIM、Major Lazer、Muse、Snoop Dogg
The Smashing Pumpkins Weezer A special performance by Breakout star Stella Lefty. I've been back to Boston, and never seen before artist collaborations you'll never see again. One wild weekend.
The Smashing Pumpkins、Weezer。由突破性明星Stella Lefty带来的特别表演。我回到了波士顿，还有前所未见的艺人合作，你再也不会看到了。一个狂野的周末。
Are you ready? Buy your tickets now at AXS.com. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你准备好了吗？现在就在AXS.com购买你的门票。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。